this warehouse usually operates ten
hours a day four days a week
packaging and shipping industrial
disinfectant products right now workers
are here seven days a week 13 hours a
day to keep up with demand from
businesses during the novel coronavirus
outbreak disinfectants have now moved
out of the clinical space into the
mainstream and I don't see that changing
in the foreseeable future
Vioxx technologies is a disinfectant
company based out of Oakville Ontario
they created the patented solution
accelerated hydrogen peroxide or AHP a
disinfectant with the ability to kill
viruses so conveyor rocks keep up with
demand and how can their products help
fight the novel coronavirus pandemic
hydrogen peroxide is active against a
wide range of microorganisms including
bacteria yeasts fungi viruses and spores
naturally speaking hydrogen peroxide is
an unstable molecule that means that it
likes to break down from hydrogen
peroxide to water and oxygen by rocks is
a HP technology combines hydrogen
peroxide and other ingredients which
Vioxx claims creates an effective
cleaning agent but one that is
environmentally friendly and safe to use
on a variety of products and materials
as businesses around the country
temporarily shatter by rocks is
producing five times more HP products
than usual today the technology is being
used in nursing homes and health care
systems like North Col Health and
cleaning companies for the virus
stricken cruise-ship diamond princess
are required to have experience with
viral products this is the area that we
call where the magic happens that's all
the innovation where novel synergies
novel technology
formulation work that leads to the
production of our antimicrobial
disinfectants here are some examples of
different formats of products that we
have we have wider bucket wipes a
smaller format buy wipes ready to use
sprays and concentrates this year you
see a wide format wipe the size of it is
larger it's mainly used for disinfecting
surfaces by jana theory and sanitary
crew the corona virus pandemic has
crippled the roughly 40 billion dollar
US cruise industry the world's four
biggest cruise lines said that they were
cutting short voyages and suspending us
sailings for a month major cruise lines
are using a HP products to disinfect
their ships so usually in the cruise
industry you have the workers using
reusable microfiber wipes and they often
put them in a little basin and pour our
disinfectant solutions to completely
saturate them they'll start disinfecting
from higher area to reach areas and do
their disinfection and make sure they
touch all the surfaces going from top to
bottom and later move to lower areas
like just surfaces and tables and
railings chairs possibly making sure
that the disinfection is evenly applied
on all surfaces in early March the EPA
released a list of products qualified
for use against the novel coronavirus
including information about the amount
of time a surface has to remain wet for
effective disinfection and whether the
product has demonstrated efficacy
against a harder to kill virus than this
one Vioxx products were there alongside
bleach ethanol and quaternary ammonium
based disinfectants among others while
these products have not been tested
specifically against the novel
coronavirus the EPA has listed them as
they have demonstrated efficacy against
a harder to kill virus or against
another similar human coronavirus
according to an EPA spokesperson our
competition is not brands it is legacy
chemistry's chemicals that we've been
used for decades sometimes 50 60 years
that have remained unchanged all the
while the bugs are mutating but
chemicals stayed the same so it's not
antara Blee difficult to disinfect a
surface it's difficult to disinfect a
surface without hurting the surface or
the person doing it and the environment
post using the cleaning and hygiene
company Diversey bought the intellectual
property rights to a HP technology from
Vioxx in december and distributes it to
more than 28 countries around the world
the company has seen an Eightfold
increase in orders of Vioxx a HP
products since the beginning of the
outbreak and it's increasing month over
month I mean if you take a look at SARS
from 2003 and you take a look at where
we are today there's been a number of
many outbreaks in between there so he
had MERS in the Middle East again
another virus transmitted from an animal
and then in between there you've had
community outbreaks of mr sav re the the
infection prevention experts call it the
bug of the week club they do not expect
that you know this is the end this is
just possibly the new norm all of this
activity will make people more prepared
more aware and you're going to see
different procedures processes put in
place in terms of state of readiness